[Musica]
non nascondo che la tentazione di
entrare immediatamente nell'argomento
covic e su quel senso opprimente di vita
tra parentesi che abbiamo vissuto
soprattutto durante il lock dow che
stiamo vivendo in un certo senso tuttora
diceva la tentazione sta molto forte
però preferisco partire dalla
definizione di parentesi dal suo
significato dal suo duplice significato
tra parentesi se parliamo di
punteggiatura e del segno grafico si
collocano le cose meno importanti
incidentali aggiuntive del discorso
figurativamente invece le parentesi
usiamo quando facciamo riferimento ad un
periodo particolare della nostra vita ad
un tempo diverso di un tempo sospeso
ora se restiamo per un po sulla
questione tipografica proprio sul segno
confesso che andando a riprende il mio
vecchio manuale di retorica su cui ho
studiato all'università e sono rimasto
molto sorpreso dal fatto che la loro
forma curvilinea anche aerodinamica se
vogliamo mi ha portato a pensare che ciò
che è contenuto al loro interno sia come
attratto dal discorso principale è come
se quella curvatura grafica
rappresentasse il segno della trazione
verso ciò che è scritto prima della
parentesi ovviamente a chiusura ciò che
è scritto dopo quindi le parentesi
contengono una porzione di scrittura
perfettamente in equilibrio tra il prima
e il dopo del discorso pensandoci bene
le parentesi che fanno parte della
punteggiatura rappresentano la parte
temporale di uno scritto quindi se le
parole rappresentano lo spazio la
punteggiatura le rappresenta il tempo
ora è chiaro che la parte tecnica la
parte tipografica
legata alla parentesi forse la meno
interessante c'è un'altra parte che
vorrei raccontarvi che fa parte
dell'esistenza di ognuno di noi
motore azione c'è un altro momento della
nostra vita in cui mettiamo appunto la
nostra vita tra parentesi a quando siamo
spettatori
quando siamo spettatori
ci sono dei momenti di come d'ingresso
quando leggiamo un libro quando vediamo
un film quando ne ma teatro quando
ascoltiamo la musica ci sono dei momenti
in cui facciamo il gesto politico quindi
cittadino di andare materialmente a
teatro di andare materialmente in
libreria e andare materialmente a
sentire un concerto
e poi ci sono quei timpani quelle
membrane temporali che sono
rappresentate per esempio nella musica
quando ascoltavamo quando erano giovani
i vinili quando appoggiavamo la puntina
sul disco si sentiva quel rumore quel
suono caldo del proprio dello
sfregamento della della puntina sul sul
vinile quel momento era uno membra
temporale che ci consentiva di entrare
dentro il tempo della musica di uscire
dalla nostra vita e ascoltare la musica
quando vediamo una copertina oggi ci
sono le copertine bellissime dei piccoli
capolavori e opere d'arte
prima di che cominci la storia prima del
libro già cominciamo ad assaporare ad
entrare dentro la scrittura di un autore
quando andiamo al cinema e ho sempre
amato i film di hitchcock mi immagino di
essere uno spettatore del cinema degli
anni 50 delle 60
mi immagino di star seduto in sala a
vedere il nuovo film di alfred isco
vertigo
[Musica]
immagino il piacere che avevano gli
spettatori quando bernard herrmann
componeva le musiche e jules bass faceva
la grafica dei titoli di testa è uno dei
momenti incredibili
quando ci sediamo in sala e sta per
cominciare un film quel momento è
fondamentale perché dimentichiamo la
vita che abbiamo vissuto fino a pochi
secondi prima ed entriamo dentro la
storia di un film
questo per dire che per esempio stanno
in un luogo sacro come questo che un
teatro esiste anche a teatro un momento
che ci consente come dire di abbandonare
la vita che abbiamo fatto fino a poco
tempo prima e di entrare dentro una
storia e l'apertura del sipario
quell'apertura così simbolica e
importante con con col panneggio che va
via e che apre la scenografia alla vista
dello spettatore rappresenta un momento
di totale apertura
come dire mentale rispetto una storia e
ci fa entrare empaticamente nei
personaggi molte volte cambiamo idea
vedendo uno spettacolo leggendo un libro
cambiamo idea sul mondo quindi sono
momenti di apertura di chiusura di
parentesi e le parentesi sono
rappresentate da ogni singola cosa che
abbiamo detto finora cioè i titoli di
testa e titoli di coda il la copertina
di un libro il suono di un vinile il
sipario che si apre non facendo parte
della tradizione di pensiero odiosa
tradizione di pensiero che sostiene che
tutto ciò che era fatto nel passato ha
più valore rispetto a ciò che viene
fatto oggi ho vissuto oggi ho
approfittato del fatto di avere dei
figli ho chiesto a mio figlio dal mio
figlio grande quali fossero le modalità
di fruizione attuali e secondo lui quali
potessero essere le parentesi temporali
che gli si aprono quando ascolta la
musica per esempio tema io ti racconto
quali sono le mie parentesi tu mi dici
qual è la tua
e lui mi ha raccontato qual è la sua
la sua è molto meno culturale è molto
più tattile legata ai sensi quando
ascolta la sua musica la musica rappo la
musica trap
loro hanno i cosiddetti ipod
la scatolina della batteria quando e
carità vibra e quella vibrazione per lui
è un accesso temporale al all'ascolto
alla durata e un altro tempo
quindi si mette tra parentesi anche lui
per arrivare poi ad esempio cardine
quello che ci vede stasera qui c'è il
teatro quando si apre il sipario
quando si apre il sipario e appare la
scenografia è chiaramente un momento di
apertura e di chiusura quando finisce di
parentesi per cui di solito le parentesi
noi la viviamo da quando siamo nati
perché siamo sempre spettatori di
qualche cosa
la parentesi dunque rappresenta
soprattutto in ambito culturale quel
particolare felice momento di accesso
alle storie è quell'elemento che le
anticipa le racchiude
certo bisogna dire che è possibile anche
una vasta estensione di significato
pensiamo alla torre di incenso che
percepisce un credente entrando in
chiesa è un'esperienza questa che
precede l'ascolto del testo il terzo tra
i testi la bibbia quell'intensa
esperienza sensoriale non fa altro che
predisporre il soggetto alla
sperimentazione di un tempo diverso
quello che appartiene al raccolto nel
suo caso anche alla comprensione del
mistero della fede ma anche esperienze
apparentemente meno culturali ma più
legate alla passione per esempio
contemplano puntualmente la presenza di
parentesi voglio fare un esempio che mi
appartiene personale
la prima volta che sono stato in uno
stadio è uno dei ricordi più belli che
conservo ricordo che la partita era
giocata in notturna ricordi aver dato la
mano a mio padre ricordo alla presenza
di un mio caro amico mio amico
dell'epoca
ricordo di aver preso le scale in
cemento dello stadio della vittoria di
essermi emozionato tantissimo nel vedere
per la prima volta questo immenso prato
verde all'interno di uno stadio
completamente gremito di persone ma
tuttora non ricordo quale fosse la
partita ora mio padre sostiene che
possono partire del bari
io invece ricordo credo fosse la partita
inter groninga infinita 5 a 0 per i
nerazzurri fortuna mia non ho corso il
rischio di tifare per l'inter da grande
ma il fatto di ricordare di
quell'esperienza la parte legata alla
parentesi quell'ingresso prima della
partita e invece non ricordare la
partita a mio parere rende l'idea di
quanto le parentesi siano importanti per
noi di quanto rappresentano le porte di
un tempo diverso e molte volte decisivo
perché chi predispone all'ascolto e alla
se penso ora in questo momento
particolare della nostra vita
al momento che stiamo vivendo
forzatamente tra parentesi allora non
posso che augurarmi che questo tempo
finisca presto e che la parentesi di
chiusura sia quella che mi ricordo
usavamo successo quando gli emoticon
ancora dei disegni ma venivano usati
ancora gli elementi della punteggiatura
e il sorriso finale era la parentesi
chiusura io mi auguro che presto arrivi
questo sorriso e che sia la parentesi di
chiusura di questo momento in cui
viviamo forzatamente separati tra di noi
e distanziati
vi ringrazio ancora per l'invito a
parlare di questo argomento
a presto
[Musica]